people still talking about the big Mad
Men finale Sunday night watched by many
people yeah yeah quite an ending
especially the use of the iconic 1971
coca-cola commercial which featured the
memorable song I'd like to buy the world
a coke yeah
very memorable ad from 1971 and people
are passing around that commercial and
rediscovering that famous song from that
era what turns out we looked into it
there was another soft drink song from
that time that some people thought was
going to be just as famous as its coke
counterpart it just never caught on I
have no idea why but I'm happy to
welcome the singer and songwriter behind
this 1971 forgotten commercial classic
called better world please welcome mr.
Stanley Park well
[Applause]
oh I don't mean to be so
what I'm telling you is not a fan
it just seems clear to see the world can
be better for you and me if we just
drink
[Music]
to the a to the B
[Music]
[Applause]
I couldn't take another second that I
just couldn't hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography